Over
to you, Chase.
>> Hey, good morning everybody. I'm uh
Lieutenant Colonel Chase Hazbrook from
US Army Cyber Command. Um going to talk
to you today about three phases of
enterprise AI adoption or the subtitle
which I should have made the main title
which is you know how I for two years
tried to drag government cyber security
personnel into using chat bots and
largely failed. So we'll talk about that
today.
Uh so disclaimer right up front. Um I'm
here on my own personal dime. The views
expressed in this presentation are my
own personal observations. Uh they do
not represent any official positions of
the US Army, Army Cyber Command or the
Department of War. So I wrote this
presentation and turned it in uh long
before the events of last week. Uh so
please please um I have no special
insight or understanding into the events
of last week. If you want to use your 30
seconds to ask me a question on the
events of last week. Uh I will give you
an answer uh that may not be to your
liking. So if you want to have a better
discussion on that topic, maybe come
find me after and we can talk about it
after. Okay.
All right. So who's this guy who's
standing in front of you? Why should you
listen to him today? I find this is
relevant context to share with people.
Um, so I joined the army 2006, did a
bunch of IT management stuff. I went to
Iraq and uh helped set up a bunch of uh
network management, IT management, uh,
calling people when satellite
communication systems are down, that
kind of thing. Um, was going to get out
and then, oh hey, the army is deciding
to stand up cyber as a actual
operational branch. This is this sounds
interesting and relevant. So I
interviewed and I joined in 2014 and
essentially helped stand up army's cyber
branch from the ground up. We can talk
about that later if you want to talk
about that. That's not what this
presentation is about. Um did a lot of
things there mostly tactical level
incident response going up to enterprise
level instant response. Um kind of
culminated where I ran the army's uh
Solar Winds Orion instant response and
run has kind of a vague context. So,
let's just leave it at ran andor
assisted andor did technical direction
andor briefed a lot of people andor
talked to a lot of senior
representatives about what did and did
not happen. Um, moved on from that,
wanted to expand and do other things.
Um, the army very graciously allowed me
to spend some time doing other stuff. So
I spent three months at DARPA as a DARPA
fellow as part of their service chiefs
fellows program in 2022 where I had a
very very small part in the AI cyber
challenge and by means by small part I
mean I got coffee for the people who
doing the actual work while uh they did
most of the work. Um I also did a little
bit of consulting with task force Lima
which if those of you who don't know was
CDAO's initial attempt to get their
hands around what is this thing called
chat GPT and why does everybody care
about it? Um, and then from there I came
back to Army Cyber and I'm kind of in a
dual role now. My day job I run
forensics and malware analysis for the
Army. That's my role at Army Cyber
Command. Um, but I also continue to work
with DARPA and I advise on emerging
technologies and things and periodically
I run uh workshops and other discussion
forums about emerging tech. Uh so last
year we did some stuff looking at
digital identity and the LLM scaling and
then this year we are specifically doing
something very similar to this
conference where we're looking at AI
security.
Okay. So, so what? So, yeah, I could
come up here. I could demo the new MCP
server for GEDra and the 10 different
forks of it and we could have a really
good and interesting talk about uh what
it means when you have uh unlimited
tokens in compute and you can throw them
as a reverse engineering workflow
against a bunch of stuff. That would be
a really fun talk. Um, unfortunately, I
can't give you that talk today because a
lot of what we've learned from that, I'm
not certain whether I'm even allowed to
tell you about it. So instead, I'm just
going to talk to you kind of my past few
years about what I've done, the pain
points I've had in trying to get both my
internal technical team uh adopting
various uh AI chatbot agents and things
and also broadly because I was kind of
like the power user who got drafted
into, hey, you're really smart at this
stuff, so why don't you come and like
help on the enterprise side with
enterprise adoption because we've rolled
out this new tool and nobody's using it.
Help us. Um so I can also talk a little
bit about that and uh some of the things
we've learned um from AI adoption from
the army cyber perspective.
All right. So but before I get started
let me set the stage a little bit. So
the army is big really really big very
very large. Um we have over a million
people when you count uh active duty
uniformed as well as national guard and
army reserve as well as all of the
civilians. We are comfortably over a
million. And also those guard and
reserve people are also part- timerrs.
So if you work in an enterprise where a
third of your million plus workforce is
part- timerrs and doing security
controls of that, please come talk to
me. I'd be interested to know how you're
handling that challenge. Um second point
this is a extremely specialized
workforce. We we don't have members of
technical staff, right? We we have lots
and lots of people who are drafted into
very specialized discrete roles where
everything is drafted up according to a
plan and everybody's expected to follow
the plan and you will follow this
ascending timeline of you will do this
at this point in your career, this point
in your career career and so on. So it's
just very specialized and I'll talk a
little more about this later about you
know where do LLMs where does that fit
in that story and then most importantly
getting new stuff is really really hard.
So in I'm going to broadly characterize
the Silicon Valley community as in many
cases you just get an API key and you
spin it up and like you're good to go
and you're using it now in your
enterprise. Good go. Uh that is
absolutely not how it works for us. So
uh we have this thing called the
authority to operate. Um but before the
authority to operate is the procurement.
So multi-year enterprise procurement
cycle those of you working in large
enterprises are very familiar with the
multi-year enterprise procurement cycle.
Um what we have which is a little
different is our enterprise security
workflow actually doesn't really execute
till after the procurement workflow. Um
and sometimes they can disagree. So we
have definitely had security products
where 2 years of procurement then 2
years of accreditation and then after
that everybody has changed out and the
new people are like yeah we don't think
that's safe anymore so you don't get to
have that thing so four years down the
drain. Just just keep that in mind. Um
one thing I'm not going to talk about
today is classification requirements. So
all of this stuff is fractal because
everything I'm talking about is just for
using them on unclassified systems or
unclassified uh up to what we currently
call kuy which is controlled
unclassified information which is still
unclassified but sensitive. Um once you
start getting into uh classification
secret and above then everything
multiplies by an order of magnitude but
I can't even talk about what that
entails. So just understand I am leaving
classification stuff out of this today.
Okay. So I will call phase one broadly
the research preview stage. Um so this
was 2023. Uh I was just coming back from
DARPA at home. I am sitting playing
around with um and I'm sure everybody
else in the room is probably doing the
same messing around with chat GT and
like writing really cool notes on
LinkedIn about oh hey there's this cool
thing called code interpreter that just
came out and it could do all your data
analysis for you mostly kind of if you
don't care about accuracy. Yeah. U so it
was really good. So I'm messing around
doing that at home and then at work I'm
seeing all the the memos. Uh so Space
Force was first with the official memo
that came out that said there will be no
enterprise use of AI period. Do not use
any AI tools. Um most of the other
services uh informally or formally went
along with that. Um so what did that
mean? So in practice you had 95% of your
workforce who already didn't care about
AI or thought it was going to take their
jobs or just hated it on general
principles and so they were very happy
to not use AI. And then you had the 5%
of power users like myself, like my
team, uh, who were very interested in
seeing, you know, testing what it could
do from nason states. And so you had a
lot of this shadow security work going
on where people would be like, yeah,
okay, I'm going to run home so I can go
throw this into uh AI Studio and see
what I get and then come back. Um, now
no actual sensitive information was
passed, but if you're just asking
questions about a capability, you can
get a lot of good information to relate
back to things. So, we were absolutely
doing a lot of that. Um, so that's mid
2023. Going into late 2023, um, we got a
new capability called Camo GPT. So, uh,
those of you who are Air Force may have
heard of Nipper GPT. Uh, that got a
little bit more press. Um, not going to
talk about that today because I'm not as
familiar with that. We were primarily
using camo which was the army's version.
Uh so this was accredited for use. It
went through the whole atto cycle in
record time in late 2023. This was
amazing. So now we no longer had to do
the the dance of go to the unapproved
tool that we're not supposed to use and
ask it questions and then come back and
then translate that into Kuey. Uh now we
can just go to this tool and actually
ask it questions with Kuey relevant data
and get answers back. Um however this
was insufficient. Why? Why was this
insufficient? Uh well three reasons. One
the models were just not good. Um for
those of you who have used uh Llama 270
uh it is it was good for its time. It
still remains you know a good LLM. But
when you're at home and your people are
using uh GPT for Turbo or I think Gemini
Pro had just come out at that point. um
going stepping back from that to the
limitations of Llama 2 uh are a lot. So
that's mostly for your power users who
are just turning up their nose at the
thing. Um for your more general users,
the bigger issue we had was um on the
front end. So uh often not thought about
but there's probably just as much work
that goes into the models on the back
end for the AI developing companies as
goes into the front end of how you're
operating with those models and
operating around them. So the two big
things that you know chat GPT had um
Gemini had uh others had um were
document parsing and web browsing. So uh
the tool we had did not have those
tools. So explaining to a general user,
okay, so you want to extract information
from a PDF, that's a great use case, but
first you need to open it up and you
need to copy and paste all of the f
stuff out of it into a text file and
then upload the text file because oh,
you can't also paste into the clipboard
because the little box only accepts, you
know, 400 something characters. So you
have to actually upload a text file and
by this point you have lost 95% of the
general user community. Um, also web
browsing like that was not a not a
thing. So there was no way to say, "Hey,
go search the internet and get context
on this." It was just limited to general
knowledge retrieval. So again, two
things made it largely unusable for
anything but a research preview. And
then finally, availability. Um, all of
this stuff was best effort. uh these
there was lots of resources that were
put into it but fundamentally it was
still um a bunch of GPUs that were
running in somebody's server farm
somewhere in the world. Um it was not
being hosted with cloud hosted data
centers or at least if it was it wasn't
you know there wasn't a lot of resource
being put to that. So in many cases you
would hit availability timeouts or if
you were trying to do anything big um
especially once we started experimenting
with rag type stuff um we were getting
uh query responses back in hours versus
minutes which clearly didn't help very
much. So yeah that's where things stood
for us in 2023.
Okay. Uh 2024 hey got a new platform
it's using commercial APIs. It's
reliable. It's got all the frontier
models. Problem solved, right?
Yeah. No tokens. So, uh, hey, guess
what? You put a premium shop in my
enterprise platform. And I'm so excited
about this. Thank you. Um, so we all got
a bunch of tokens to use. And for
bureaucratic political reasons, there
was no designation of power users versus
normal users. So, everybody got one
allocation of tokens. And without naming
the provider, um the provider basically
took the generalized API cost that you
could get through uh your AWS's or your
Azures and they just multiplied that by
a factor of 10 to get their profit
margin and they sold that back to us. So
equivalently uh what happens is for
general use office use case you know
mostly fine for the average user who's
asking you know summarize this two-page
document fine help me draft this three
paragraph email fine but for my
forensics guys who are like okay I've
got a 20page log file and I want you to
I'm going to put that in there and then
I want you to compare it to this other
20page log file from 3 days ago and I
want you to diff it and look for you
know not just diffs, but actual like
meaningful differences. Um, yeah, you do
that once and okay, half your quote is
gone for the month. So, we we brought
this up as a problem and they said, "Oh,
we acknowledge this is a problem and
here is the process for how you fix it.
You ask for more tokens and this
requires seven signatures and seven
justifications for very high ranking
people who don't understand what an LLM
is." So yeah, in practice the the
process was uh let's let's call it
effectively impossible.
So fundamentally we were still using
camo GPT for what we could. We were
burning our tokens by like day one or
two and then everybody was still going
and using AI studio though we don't talk
about that. All right so we're caught up
to today right phase three fancy
enterprise agreements. Those of you
might know genai.mill just rolled out.
It's the DoDwide AI platform. Uh several
major AI enterprise platforms are
connecting to it. So now if you're a
worker within the department, you can
just go to genai.mill and you can hit
what's there and use the enterprise
versions. So not somebody's like
self-wrapped, self-hosted, you know,
hey, we're just wrapping the API with
our own custom web front end, but the
actual has the good UI front end that
these tools have developed. So that's
what's coming. Um so now we're into
culture challenges right so one of the
problems we have in the army is uh this
thing called what I call the silo reflex
which is whenever a new technology comes
out we put it in a box and we say okay
Joe you're really smart at this new tech
so you're the box guy anytime any
questions come up about the box any
generals want know have questions about
the box I'm gonna say Joe's the smart
guy in the box and he's gonna answer all
your questions for you and that's fine
like that's that's a starting point that
you have to do that like you know back
in the day there was the computer guy
and anytime anybody had any questions
about computers it was like go talk to
Joe he's a computer guy he'll answer
your computer box questions um I was the
cyber guy for a long time I was the guy
who owned the cyber box and people ask
me questions about the cyberbox and I
would say yes I can tell you lots of
cool things about the cyber box
is this a good idea uh it's it's always
a good idea to start the question is do
you need to progress past that um in
many cases maybe you like so you know
space or um these are technologies that
it's okay that you probably leave it in
a box and you just have a specialist who
comes and talks to you about it.
Obviously if you're in the space force
not so much space but if you're in the
army we don't do too much with space as
affecting the whole enterprise. So you
can probably safely leave that in a box.
Um things like GPS and computers uh
those clearly should not have been in
the box and those should have been
generalized as soon as possible. So the
faster we can get those out there, the
better. Um, cyber still kind of figuring
out how much the whole enterprise needs
to be part of that versus just a
specialized in the box thing. Drones is
a little newer of a tech same battle.
We're battling that right now where do
we have a drone core that is the people
who do just the drones and they're the
drone experts for everybody or do we
push drones out to all of our fighting
forces and say you guys are all going to
be drone experts now because that's the
future of war fighting. Uh, again, still
figuring that out. So, you know, the
takeaway is AI. Is this going to look
more like VR or more like PCs? I would
say last year it's definitely tipping
more in the PC direction. Before that,
you can make a case for either side. Um,
but that's interesting. I'm not sure how
it's going to play out.
All right. So, overall what I've talked
about today is this is the pattern,
right? You have an access problem. We
solved the access problem. We solved
that by centralization. Uh then we moved
on to cost problems. Uh we solved that
by enterprise agreements and now we're
on phase three which is a cult culture
problem. What is going to solve this?
Like what are we going to learn? um how
are we going to figure out that a lot of
the requirements documents, you know,
going back to that original like
four-year requirement discussion we had
before, a lot of our requirements
documents right now, they exist as
people's chat histories on various LLM
platforms. So how do we extract the
knowledge out of those chat histories
and actually get it from the operators
down at the lower technical levels and
get it to the enterprise procurement
folks so they can understand these are
the types of questions people are asking
and we need to take those questions and
we need to wrap them in some kind of
tool that the rest of the enterprise can
broadly be familiar with.
All right, that's my talk. So I'm
retiring October 26 and I'm exploring
what's next. So please feel free to come
out and talk to me about any of that
today. Thank you.
>> All right. First of all, I I don't think
your slides are up. Uh shared, right?
>> What's up?
>> You haven't shared your slides.
>> I will share I will share the slides in
the Slack.
>> Okay. Yes. Great. Um there's a thread
for that. All right. Questions? Any
questions? Okay. Any other questions
before?
>> Is our cy our cyber thinking about
extending those capabilities to the
reserve component because we're not on
nipper.
are
geni.m mill or what?
>> Yeah. So, jai.mill is available to
everybody in the dood. Um, now the act
the problem of getting people onto
nipper so that they can access that tool
which only lives on nipper is still
absolutely a challenge. I completely
understand that. Um, there are tools for
this. Uh, we do have uh Azure virtual
desktop. Uh, we have some mobile tools
that are coming out. We have some BYOD
tools coming out. Um I am not the
program manager for those tools. Uh it
is something that is thought about but
fully acknowledge that there are
absolutely challenges for garden reserve
that are probably not being met as well
as they could.
>> Hey, it's John Fage. I teach uh I'm over
here Chase.
>> Okay.
>> I teach at a local university malware
analysis. So from your perspective and
including AI. So, any advice on what
you're looking for in future
uh military folks when it comes to
malware and AI?
So, I would say uh what we're looking
for primarily is people who are not just
solving challenges in a vacuum but
understand um how to take those
technical challenges and relate them
back to uh key problems that people are
having. Right? This isn't a thing that's
new to AI in general. Um, this is a
problem that's okay, you wrote a
technical report, you solved some
things, great, but why is that useful?
What is what is the so what of that? Um,
and AI could potentially help you with
that with some degree, but you have to
have enough of the level of
understanding to be able to go back to
the chatbot and say, "Okay, help me boil
this down for a non-technical
stakeholder who doesn't need seven pages
of here's all the methods I decompiled
and here's what they do and here's the
hooks they have and here's uh what the
processes it affects." They just need to
know like can I turn the thing back on
or do I have to wait for two more days
before I can turn the thing back on. So,
as long as you can, you know, think
about how you can translate it in that
perspective. Um, obviously this depends
on if you're looking more at senior
roles or at junior roles, but um, yes,
that's kind of where I would go with
that.
>> Great. Thanks.
>> Um, with regard to the AI being sort of
centralized, can you talk a little bit
more, uh, how you handle fine-tuning or
specialized model for individual
departments and specialized teams? Do
those get housed in the same centralized
location?
>> So, we haven't seen a lot of benefit to
uh fine-tuning models or specializing
models yet. Our procurement cycles are
so long that um by the time you
successfully fine-tune or specialize a
model, the general model has advanced
long enough that you're not getting the
advantages from the fine-tuned or
specialized models. Um that might change
in the future. Um but right now I would
say more of the value comes not from
providing the fine-tuned or specialized
model but from providing an actual
bespoke
uh workflow and task that is relevant
and legible to procurement. So I'm not
giving you a fancy model. I'm completing
this task for you and it's done and you
don't have to worry about asking
chatbots how to do it.
>> Any other questions?
All right, very good, Chase. Thanks very
much.
And uh thank you for your service. I'm
sure you hear that all the time. So,
all right. Thanks very again.